hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report hey we're kicking off summer
solutions every summer we talk about
the solutions and uh instead of dwelling
on the problems you know we got
answers we've got solutions stacy
max well i'll show you a problem and why
bitcoin fixes this why bitcoin was the
solution it is the ultimate solution
that fixes
many things as you and i have discussed
for the past 10 years
but it's becoming more and more obvious
why well you know kim kardashian she's
an advisor to many uh politicians and
and presidents and sort of that sort of
thing with her
um various quips on social media and
meetings with presidents as well
she had said something which i realized
that maybe
central banks may have been paying
attention to and why
our problems persist she had said if you
can fix a problem with money
it's not really a problem hence they
keep throwing money
at our problems and they don't disappear
because that was never
good advice right you just can't throw
money at a problem
and make it disappear right right the
printing will continue until morale
improves
you know um this is uh the facile
thinking
of an insta celebrity concatenated
out of the imagination of a network
executive who
got really bored one day and decided
that they didn't want to pay for talent
they were going to print money and
create a fiat celebrity
and then pump that up with more not only
money but other things
pump it up you've got to pump it up
right kim
and the bigger the pump the bigger the
celebrity and the more money printing
that's happened
and uh the result is what we call the k
recovery k-shaped recovery
massive billionaires versus entrenched
underclass and poverty in america
thanks kim she did of course pump up her
i'm hoping people caught the double
entendre there the pump
pump it up you've got to pump it up but
you know some some guys like that
some guys like that we're going to get
to the hamptons in the second half and
that's
the sort of thing you see in the
hamptons as well but you know um
when summer solution started a few years
ago one thing that was often talked
about by the likes of michael hudson and
uh steve keane was a debt jubilee and of
course a debt jubilee wiping out the
debts of the debtors
um basically annihilates like it
it hurts the creditors i.e the wall
street banks
the private equity the hedge funds all
the elite
that never happened so what we're seeing
today instead of the results they've
made their choice
joe biden is there to deliver the choice
you know he's always been a spokesperson
essentially
for uh you know a politician for the
credit card industry which is
the the pinnacle in terms of cantillon
effect that we've talked about
the the elite get zero percent money or
one percent money
uh the the schmucks and the deplorables
get uh 20
money on their credit cards right credit
on their credit cards
so i mean everybody is now talking even
central bankers are talking about
inflation
perhaps hyperinflation coming so in a
way i'm
considering this what we see in the
cryptocurrency markets
i money that's not as good as bitcoin
what you see is a thing called a rug
pull
so this hyperinflation is a rug pull
they're like destroy
they're they're basically pumping this
up they have the assets which are real
assets hard assets like
property uh land uh madiglianis as you
often talk about
gold uh bitcoin they the wealthy and the
elite have these things and
that is going to go up in value while
they're pulling the rug under the u.s
dollar and we've seen that
as we've mentioned with the imf talking
about a new britain woods coming
and that wef talking about a great reset
so i'll tell you what a rug pull is just
in case you don't know a rug pull is a
malicious maneuver
in the cryptocurrency industry where
crypto developers abandon
a project and run away with investors
funds
abandon the project right uh exit scam
you know the the biggest nexus scam is
ether
and then there's this other one cardano
these are exit scams
and our rug pulls and um xrp uh elon
musk did a rug pull with doge
recently he went on saturday night live
and pumped the price like kim
kardashian's
ashian and then did a pull
so it's a cheap cheap man's version of a
ponzi scheme i mean bernie
madoff managed to keep a legitimate
ponzi scheme going for many years these
elon musk style rug polls are cheap
imitations
well those are cryptocurrencies what i
want to really focus on
is that you know the entire crypto
market including bitcoin
was like 2.3 billion the entire
u.s dollar market in terms of all the
derivatives all the credit
all the debt all the cash is
quadrillions
so here they're doing a rug pull they're
abandoning the project
called the us dollar as a reserve
currency as the grid of the global
internet
of the global economy so you're seeing
that you're seeing them that's why
you're seeing them talking about the
great reset that's why you see them
talking about a new bretton woods that's
why you see them printing like this
that's why you see
uh joe biden putting forth a six
trillion dollar budget this is a rug
bull they're rug
pulling the rug bitcoin fixes this this
is what we've been saying for 10 years
right right the us dollar is the
ultimate rug poll
look anytime you move off the gold
standard you're talking about a ponzi
scheme
by definition because you've got to keep
printing to keep the base of the ponzi
going
and to pay off the early investors with
printing more money and that's
the ultimate ponzi scheme is the us
dollar and the ultimate rug pull or trap
door
or exit scam is the u.s dollar and a lot
of people
know it and they're positioning
themselves ahead of it
bitcoin does fix this because it brings
back the equivalent of a gold standard
but it's
much better than a gold standard and the
results will be
uh quite dramatic and this is all
building up toward maybe july 4th we'll
see
some epic kind of collapse in the dollar
which would be very um kind of a big
pageant wouldn't it it'd be great be the
fireworks american flag and a us dollar
rug pull that could be fantastic
rug pulled on the fourth of july yes
that could be happening and you know
what you know i think bitcoin forced
their hand
to do the exit scam now on the 50th
birthday
of the us dollar as an all fiat reserve
standard we're going to hearken back
we're going to look back
at a quote from
frederick hayek now frederick hayek was
around during the last transition from
an empire
you know the last thucydides trap we saw
and the last collapse of a reserve
currency which was the british pound at
the time
and uh wrote the road to serfdom but he
said something interesting back in 1984
and this is a quote from a reddit thread
of bitcoin
i don't believe we shall ever have a
good money again
before we take the thing out of the
hands of government
that is we can't take it violently out
of the hands of government
all we can do is by some sly roundabout
way
introduce something that they can't stop
so i'm going to then from there hayek in
turn to what jason furman recently was
quoted as saying
now jason furman was an economic advisor
to barack obama
and at that time of course max and stacy
were also
first starting here on kaiser report in
2009 during the financial crisis
and they missed the opportunity as we
said
to uh kill bitcoin at that time jason
furman
i wish we had smothered this meaning
bitcoin
a decade ago before it grew into a two
trillion dollar monster digital
currencies are all
cons and no pros environment crime
taking advantage of unaware investors
if they had any use at all we could
debate it
but they don't have any use at all right
right so the high quote very famous
quote
and bitcoin does satisfy what he talks
about in that quote and that the only
way you could separate
the state from money is through some sly
kind of uh mirage or something that went
unnoticed
and that's exactly what happened with
bitcoins and now we've got a
separation of state of money the second
quote refers to the fact that at the
first few months of bitcoin's birth
there
would have been a a moment of time maybe
where the state could have done
something to stop it
uh but it was it never did and now it's
hit escape velocity and now every
central bank in the world is going to go
under
every nation state will have to be
reorganized around
the fact that people now have their own
wealth it's unconfiscatable
it's immutable you can't censor it even
you know going back to when we were
covering this in the early days in 2009
there was talk about allowing wikileaks
to accept bitcoin
but satoshi the famous originator uh
wrote in his notes that he thought it
would draw too much attention
to bitcoin so they did not overtly
uh allow for wikileaks to uh go into
bitcoin even though they were being
censored by
credit card companies and paypal at that
time well
he says as well that bitcoin has no use
at all
whereas it it provides the use case
of a store value unconfiscated both
store value
on censorable store value for billions
of people around the world
and on top of that it provides
incentives it is more capitalist in
terms of allocating capital
you don't want to you don't want to just
allocate your precious bitcoin
on dumb stuff and dumb investments like
we've seen
as the money printing continues because
morale
does not improve enough in fact what
we've seen
is an increase in mortality rates
outside even the pandemic what we've
seen is the opioid overdoses
the preliminary numbers for last year is
that they were close to 90 000 opioid
overdoses in the u.s versus like
70 000 the year before so there's a big
increases in
deaths of despair under what he thinks
is the better system
of printing money which is causing the
wealth and income gap
look bitcoin provides for
everybody on earth for the first time
true private property it gives property
rights private property rights to
individuals in a way that's
never ever ever ever ever been available
before up until bitcoin it was agreed
between the state
and the people that certain rights would
be obeyed
and in every single case going back
that's 2 000 years every single state
has violated those rights and stolen
people's property
and america is no different today
they're
overtly stealing americans property by
the hundreds of billions and
trillions and it's very sad but bitcoin
allows not only americans and europeans
but africans and asians and south
americans by people in mexico mexico
city right on viva la mexico
property rights for the first time ever
therefore
obviating the need for the state and
obviously killing the need for any
central bank
right if you can fix a problem with
money it's not really a problem
you could fix these problems with
bitcoin money but the fact is that the
us dollar is not
and no fiat currency is money let me
correct her quote
this quote shouldn't read if you can't
fix it with money it's not really a
problem
the quote to be accurate should read if
you can't fix it with money it's not
really money
exactly exactly exactly so the incentive
structure is the
the look at what we're witnessing now as
they're printing more and more money
we're seeing um these just
not only prices gapping up but shortages
exploding all over
and here's from barons 10 ways to cash
in on the shortage of
just about everything america's chicken
sandwich war has the combatants
scrambling for supplies
breast prices have doubled this year
chick-fil-a has run low on sauce
burger king has had pickle problems jars
not cucumbers are hard to come by
an isolated supply squeeze anyone who's
building or remodeling a home or buying
or renting a car or stocking up on pool
chlorine or dog food
knows better in the land of plenty there
suddenly seems to be an
everything shortage right the breast
supplies are in shortage
is not also a reference to kim
kardashian
all right we're gonna take a break and
when we come back more
yeah well we're back this is the kaiser
report summer solutions
my name is max kaiser i'm here with
stacy herbert
right so we were talking about shortages
in the first half
i want to talk about oversupply in the
second half and how
money i the the the confusion
of fiat money with money
and how it caused an oversupply well it
caused an over
supply of the elite overproduction of
the elite we've covered this before
that's a concept
made popular by peter turchin i believe
he's at wesleyan
in connecticut university so as we've
been printing all this money
and remember the printing of the money
is in order to fix the problem
of the pandemic lockdowns and the
wealth gap remember that's what they say
that's why they're printed all that
money
the trillions of dollars and they
expanded on the fed's balance sheet
but also the government debt you know
the treasury printed a whole bunch of
bonds to send to people
well billionaire wealth reaching 20
of gdp risk of overheating says gabriel
zuckman
and his research this is just looking at
the us other all
countries are similarly bad but in the
us
as the center of the empire right wealth
of the top 400 wealthiest americans
is now close to 20 of gdp
it started at the pandemic at 15
so as you see it's gapping up it's
considered
uh kind of racist to say or you know
evil to say that you uh there was a good
time in america that
a few decades ago things might have been
better
obviously things were worse and in many
ways
for women for uh black americans but
if you look at what they were aiming for
what they're really talking about
when people are are talking about when
america was great
look at this back in 1980
when we were uh teenagers and entering
the workforce
the top 400 families owned less than
three percent of us gdp
so that's what people are talking about
you can call it anything else like
you know that you're sexist if you uh if
you are against
the 20 of the gdp that the top 400
families have
or you can say well you know this is an
economic structure
that is ruining the country and the
world like the financial system is
ruining the world
right well that number of uh 20 of
america's gdp
now is billionaires is going to go to
because that's called feudalism and this
is neo-feudalism
and we've been saying this for at least
five years that the money printing
because it doesn't go through the
economy it goes right into the pockets
of the billionaires remember you can
clearly see that through the money
velocity number which keeps going down
to zero
because the money doesn't get circulated
it just goes into the pockets of the
neo-feudal class and so it's going to go
to 100
because there's politically everyone's
been disenfranchised
you know they're the political
machinations that the politics of
representational government have been
dismantled
they've been destroyed by
uh design by the billionaires right
so uh the reason why bitcoin is at tens
of thousand dollars a coin is because
it's
showing that the us dollar and other
fiat money are
already in a hyperinflationary collapse
against bitcoin
the only way anyone's going to survive
the neo feudalization of this economy in
america and around the world
is through unconfiscatable bitcoin yes
there will be an incredibly difficult
time
dead ahead because we're entering into
the fourth turning
meets kind of like the jim jones
massacre
if you remember that from the 80s and
going back to the jim jones look that up
kids
uh the jim jones massacre where we come
up with the expression oh i'm drinking
the kool-aid
do a little research on where that comes
from so you've got jim jones meets the
fourth turning meets jamie dimon
meets um goldman sachs you put that all
together give it a shake
and that's what they're asking us to
drink well
combine all of those into the hamptons
because
i'm going to predict that the
that will be the the hot spot of
this problem of the overproduction of
the elite
because what peter churchian argues and
what we've covered here on the kai's
report
is that when there are too many elite
and and the
you know the pie is fixed in terms of
how much graft that you could take
from the taxpayer and bailouts and free
money from the taxpayer
they start going at each other and one
of the classic examples of that is
steve bannon who is an elite who went to
elite
universities was a you know a
multi-multi-millionaire
and he uh turns against the elite so
you'll have more of that you have that
in the french
revolution period uh when the elites are
starting to turn on each other
so here is the conflict in the hamptons
building up and we've been following us
because max and i go out to
montauk which is past the hamptons it's
considered more like
real you have fishermen still there
working all year long and stuff like
that
but they're running out of room in the
hamptons and those elites of the hampton
southampton sag harbor east hampton
amaganset they're pushing out into
montauk
surf lodge preparing to turn people away
as hampton's summer ramps up after a
pandemic slow down the hamptons are
heating up again for this summer with
sold-out hotels
packed rentals endless helicopters and
sky-high prices on just about everything
hot spot surf lodge montauk is so
worried
about the crowds they're asking people
to please
stay away this is again feudalism
everybody had to build their own castle
hire their own army if you're going to
defund the police which of course the
liberal elites are all about defunding
the police to satisfy
their oligarchic masters at comcast uh
they're gonna have to hire their own
police force
and so they'll go to war with each other
on east hampton beach
or something like that they'll be like
the baldwin's
militia will be scoring off against the
pearlman's militia
and uh you know some other uh maybe uh
carl icons militia
and and steven spielberg's militia will
meet on hampton beach
and they'll and they'll reengage and and
do battle with each other
uh with uh slingshots arrows and uh
copyright
law saying i own the rights to this
battle no i own the rights of this
battle i just sold to hbo i'm making a
mini-series i'm the star
so it'll be like disney
meets patton right so it's gonna be walt
disney
meets caligula on in the hamptons
this summer coming soon to hbo
right well that sounds like a good
series of course there was a series
called the and
which is based out in montauk
so as you see they're all like working
class out there
they were as and and now you're seeing
conflict if you go on the facebook pages
of the montage pages they're like these
hamptons dudes better
stay out but there you know there's just
too many elite and the exclusive entry
into the exclusive schools
you saw that with the the whole uh you
know parents
bribing officials to get into schools
thing now you're seeing it with these
elite
um venues like the surf lodge where the
likes of justin bieber and stuff hang
out when they're
there in town it's just at the edge of
montauk and
hampton so it's like acceptable to have
some of them in there but they're
pushing in
so you're seeing conflict you know it
made me also think of of course we have
elite overproduction
in saudi arabia right there's like 7 000
princes
and declining oil supply so you have
more and more princes to feed and
palaces to build and jets to give them
and
what happened what did we see in the
last few years when prince alwaleed
was hung by his feet and the ritz of
course in the ritz um in
uh in riyadh yeah that's coming to the
crab shack in the hamptons this weekend
billionaires health
suspended by their ankles and being
whipped uh
by their agents uh in an attempt to get
even more work
uh in this new hbo series collugula
meets
walt disney's version of the sound of
music as
told by those who have been weaned
on uh fresh milk from the ewes
that they keep on the farm we could see
that if they tried to venture out as far
as gurneys or
like gasmans and montauk if you get out
to gasman's like you're
you're in real danger you need a pied
piper who arrives
uh with the fiat money pie piper pipe
and then all the billionaires march into
the sea and drown
you know that would be i think the story
i'm gonna write
is showtime presents the pied piper of
the hamptons
watch 30 000 billionaires march into the
sea and
drown and the day is saved well it's
certainly going to be hot i believe
out in the hamptons as the conflicts
emerge between the
all the entitled the very entitled
karen's who feel like
um they deserve you know all the money
that was printed and given to them that
they deserve something exclusive with
that
but what they're noticing is that more
and more people
were actually given money by the fed and
that they're having to compete now for
space and live
like a deplorable so you know if
everyone's a billionaire then nobody's a
billionaire exactly that's what i'm
saying is this is is getting to that
point where they're starting to realize
that hey i i remember when having you
know 20 billion dollars was like made me
ron perlman king of the hamptons now
it's like every schmuck in town like
stars on stars of only fans are buying
houses only fans start have you seen
this yeah they're they're buying
multi-million dollar flats for the
hamptons
for shaking their booty on only fans
right so how do you
present an academy award-winning actor
who's got his fingers in you know kim
kardashian's spandex
can it abide by this injustice
well we have a whole bunch of more
boondoggles coming up to
possibly make you even more exclusive to
be able to offer like a hundred billion
for for that um apartment the house on
the beach
that the only fan stars are competing
with you know so we have the six
trillion dollar budget that
uh biden has has planned um there is no
there is no uh plan to abolish the debt
of the student debt remember he he
used that to get into office that's a
rock ball that's a wrong poll it was joe
biden king of the rug polls
student debt forgiveness run
uh you know universal health care rogue
pool
there's jimmy dore on his show every
night every chronicling joe biden's
rug pull and then the young turks are
over there like oh my god oh my god it
was a rock paul we're so silly
it's rug pull right of course oh yeah
but uh or it could be ron paul he's got
merkins on his eyebrows but uh so in the
last minute and a half here we're gonna
say
like we're heading into the summer
solutions we're going to do a few
episodes coming up and then we'll take
a break return to normal programming and
then we're going to do some more summer
solutions
as the summer goes on but obviously
bitcoin fixes this it fixes all the
problems because you fix the money and
you fix all the economic and monetary
problems
you fix the billionaire thing like the
the problems with the billionaires
max's movie sees them all running uh go
into the sea
but i think bitcoin is a is a more
peaceful way to just like
this that's the end of the first act is
just like bitcoin fixes it and it's over
like it'll be the first feature film to
have one act but we have
you know we have james howard counselor
coming up we have marshall
auerbach and we have uh tyson slocum and
the interesting thing is that they were
all
in our series called front running and
the front-running series was looking at
what the democratic candidates for
president
were uh proposing at that time and they
all seemed really radical and really
crazy ideas like mmt
ubi debt forgiveness and all that sort
of stuff hyperinflation wasn't
one of the solutions that was on offer
but that seems to be the solution
that joe biden is uh has introduced
and um we think it's a bad solution
bitcoin is a better solution
he seems to hark and have a like deep
longing for the 70s that's where he
started his career and maybe that's
where he wants you gotta
pump it up hey pump it up joe
gotta pump it up hey that's gonna do it
for this
special summer solutions entree with
the main course max kaiser and the
dessert stacey herbert
if you enjoyed this feast stay tuned to
other episodes coming your way
until then bye y'all
[Music]
you